المراه ايضا رائده الصالح يعود الينا من
جديد المدير العام للدفاع المدني السوري
من شمال سوريا سيد رائد الصالح كنت تتحدث
اذا عن
نطاق
تضرر هذه المواقع في شمال سوريا
والحصيله ايضا المتوفره لديكم تفضل
لدينا حصيله او يعني نستطيع التحدث عنها
هناك عشرات العائلات الان واخرين تحت
الانقاض هناك احياء بشكل كامل يعني حقيقه
انهارت فوق اهلها هناك يعني المدن الاكثر
تضررا لدينا هي
الدانه حارم سلقين ادلب كفر تخاريم جسر
الشغور
الاتارب وقرى وايضا مدينه جنديرس هناك قرى
مثل الجيني والرمادي ودركوش والملل وغيرها
الطرق اللي نحن استنفرنا كافه فرق الدفاع
المدني الان تستجيب الاولويه ليست بالعدل
والاحصاء عندما الاولويه هي
للاستجابه وانقاذ
[موسيقى]
الطبعه التي مهدده بالانهيار في اي وقت
ممكن لذلك الوضع صعب جدا حقيقه الان على
جميع سيد رائد الصالح في عمليه الوصول الى
العالقين في هذه المرحله
حقيقه يعني نحن نعمل بكل طاقتنا حتى نصل
للمدنيين العالقين تحت الانقاذ قبل قليل
تم انتشال فتاه
ووالدتها من تحت الانقاص في مدينه سرمدا
ايضا تم انتشار ثلاث اطفال في مدينه حارم
تم انتشار عدد من الجرحى ايضا في الملند
والرمادي ولكن يعني نحن نستمر بالاعمال
ولكن حقيقه تركيا كدوله وهي خبيره في
موضوع الزلازل طلبت المساعده او المسانده
الدولي اكيد نحن كفرق ايضا نطالب
بالمسانده والمساعده الدوليه هناك احتياج
كبير لتقديم الاغاثه للمدنيين الموجودين
في الخلاء اضف الى ذلك المدنيين الذين
موجوده تحت الانقاض يعني الفرق بحاجه الى
دعم اضافي اضافي الى ذلك ان
تقديم لغاتي العاجل دون المرور بالسياسات
السابقه التي كانت تمرنا وخاصه حاليا يعني
شمال غرب سوريا يعاني من نقص في التمويل
في المستشفيات يعاني من ايقاف
المستوصفات يعاني من ايقاف مراكز الطبيه
ايضا هذا كله يعني حقيقه سيؤدي الى
الزياده الوضع سوءا وخاصه ان قص النظام
سابقا
لهذه المدن والبلدات ادى الى زياده عدد
الامني المنهاره بشكل كبير جدا نحن نعمل
كل ما علينا لا نستطيع الان اصدار اي
تقديرات نحن اعلنا المنطقه هي منطقه
منكوبه نحن بحاجه الى مساعده سريعه حقيقه
نرجو من من جميع من يسمعني ان كان في قطر
او اي دوله عربيه اخرى انت تستطيع التواصل
معنا بشكل مباشر حتى تستطيع ان نقدم
المساعده بشكل عاجل الى اهلنا في شمال
سوريا ما الذي يصعب من مهامكم الان السيد
رائد الصالح ان كان في عمليات ازاله
الركام واجلاء العقل العالقين انتم كدفاع
مدني
ما الذي يصاعد من مهامكم
يعني حقيقه
كبيره جدا من حيث عدد الاليات المتوفره
لدينا ايضا الى ذلك من حيث عدد الامكانيات
اللوجستيه التي يعني نحن
كباقي المؤسسه الحقيقه نعاني من نقص في
التمويل لا يوجد لدينا احتياطات كبيره من
الديزل لتشغيل هذه الاليات يمكن حقيقه نحن
ان يكون لدينا نقص كبير في المواد مع مع
استمرار العمليات واستمرار العمل ويمكن ان
ان نتوقع ان تتوقف بعض الاليات ايضا عن
العمل اذا حقيقه اذا اذا نفذت الديزل او
اذا نفذ حقيقه الوضع
كارثه جدا يعني هناك عمليه التخفيف
المساعدات او عمليه تقييد المساعدات او
يعني تخفيض حجم الاموال المخصصه للدعم
لشمال غير سوريا هذا كله ادى الى
تفاقم الوضع بالاضافه الى ذلك يعني دعيني
اقول ان هناك مراكز طبيه اقفلت قبل اشهر
هناك مستشفيات توقفت الان الكادر الطبي
الكادر الاسعاف المستشفيات المستوصفات
مراكز الفرق الدفاع المدنيه كلها تعمل
بجميع طاقتها كامله وحتى نستطيع ان تلبي
حجم الاحتياجات اتمنى ان ان ان نسرع باسرع
وقت ممكن حتى حقيقه كلما زادت سرعه
الاستجابه كلما زادت عدد الحياه التي
نستطيع انقاذها مع مرور الوقت
نشاهد هذه الصور التي التقطت قبل قليل من
التي تضررت ايضا من هذا الزلزال وكنا
نشاهد
المباني التي تبررت وانهار بعضها في
اللاذقيه كما ذكرنا وهذه الاليات التي
تدخل الى هذا الحي من اجل التعامل مع
الركام الذي خلفه هذا الزلزال
والبحث ربما عن العالقين داخل المباني
المتضرره وما هو واضح من خلال هذه الصور
ان الاهالي غادروا منازلهم يقفون في
الشوارع خوفا ربما من هزات ارتداديه وخوفا
من انهيار منازلهم التي تصدعت وتضررت جراء
هذا الزلزال كنا نتابع قبل قليل من ذكر
بانه
لجا الى سيارته مع عائلته
للاحتماء نتيجه تضرر البنايه
التي يقطنون فيها نشاهد كذلك في على
شاشاتنا ادلب نشاهد ديار بكر اورفا وكرمان
مارش مركز الهزه الارضيه الرئيسيه بقوه 7
درجات واربع اعشار الدرجه على مقياس ريختر
سيد رائد الصالح
وزاره الصحه السوريه تتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد
ضحايا الزلزال في عموم سوريا الى
237 قتيلا وستمائه وتسعه وثلاثين مصابه
اين ربما
سقط اغلب القتلى اي المدن السوريه التي
تضررت اكثر جراء هذا الزلزال
وسقط فيها العدد الاكبر من القتلى والجرحى
وتضررت المباني اكثر ايضا
نعم يعني نحن انا غير قادر يعني حتى وزاره
الصحه السوريه غير قادر ان تحدد هي غير
موجوده في في شمال غرب سوريا تستطيع ان
تتكلم عن المناطق التي تعمل بها وانا لا
استطيع ان اتكلم بدقه عن الارقام لكن
اعتقد ستكون من اكبر المدن المتضرره هي
مدينه حلب
كن هذه المدينه تعرضت لقصف عنيف سابق من
النظام ومعظم الابنيه اصلا تتساقط بدون
زلازل يعني شاهدنا الاسبوع قبل يومين سقوط
منزل في الفردوس بناء وقبل اسبوع سقوط
بناء ايضا
بالشيخ مقصود
ارتفع عدد الكبير بصراحه من يعني انا
وصلتني الان احصائي اولى من شمال غرب
سوريا لدينا 58 قتيل 179 مصاب طبعا العدد
مرشح للازدياد بشكل كبير جدا لانه هناك
عائلات كثيره جدا انا اعتقد المدينه
الاكثر تضررا ستكون حلب جراء الطواريخ
المتطوره التي تحدثنا عنها في 2016 و 2017
التي استخدمتها روسيا والتي قال عنها وزير
الدفاع الروسي انها
جربت كثير من الاسلحه بنجاح
اعتقد سيكون هناك انهيارات كبيره جدا في
في تلك في مدينه حلب وستكون المدينه
الاكثر تضررا وسيكون العدد الاكبر من
الضحايا المدنيين اتمنى السلام لاهلنا انا
اعتذر لن استطيع
الاستمرار كون لدينا يعني لدي اعمال
ومتابعه الاعمال
جزيل الشكر الرائده الصالحه المدير العام
للدفاع المدني السوري كنت معنا من شمال
سوريا شكرا على هذه